[Music]
ah the holidays a time for quiet
peaceful reflection on the year that's
gone by and what a year it's been we saw
the aviation industry back in
coronavirus and staff shortages billions
were poured into ev toll companies cop
26 made us re-evaluate how we fueled the
future the chip shortage led to car
production woes rivien and lucid
released their game-changing cars
driverless vehicles began popping up on
more and more roads tesla rolled out its
fsd beta and drew criticism from a
federal crash investigator there were
more spike mergers than you could shake
a stick at and we sent some billionaires
up into space
makes you wonder what next year could
bring right well here's what's likely to
be making the headlines in 2022
let's start with the roads it's likely
they'll continue to be as full of cars
as ever it's just that next year more of
those cars will be electric they're a
vision of the future that is now
beginning to happen biden's bipartisan
infrastructure bill is promising
billions towards expanding the us's ev
charging network which already grew in
2021 it's part of the reason why evs are
forecast to make up four percent of all
new car sales in the us in 2022 that
means you're to start to see more evs on
the road and not just teslas there's a
slew of automakers ready to try and
capture that demand ford is expected to
start deliveries of its f-150 lightning
the electrified version of america's
most popular pickup at the start of next
year lucid is releasing its cheaper
lucid air pure and rivien will ramp up
deliveries of their r1s suv while at the
same time developing a new factory near
atlanta georgia production is scheduled
to begin on fiskars ocean at the tail
end of next year and while we're not
entirely sure if 2022 will be the year
that tesla's cyber truck finally makes
an appearance on our streets what we do
know is that next year the company is
likely to start delivering vehicles from
its austin and berlin plants and that
will expand the company's global
presence and bolster its manufacturing
capabilities
but it's not just the cars we drive that
could be seeing an update next year
driverless car companies have big plans
too see in october this year gm's ceo
said she was pretty confident that cruz
the company's robo taxi arm would be
able to remove the support drivers from
their vehicles in 2022 and intel have
announced that mobileye its autonomous
driving company will be going public
next year and while car manufacturers
continue to roll out their advanced
driver assistance platforms one
automaker has big plans for next year
and for once i am not talking about
tesla
mercedes has received approval to roll
out its level 3 autonomous drive pilot
software in germany in 2022 level 3
autonomy if you don't know means that
you can take your eyes off the road
until the car says it needs your
attention again and tesla while selling
a software called full self-driving is
actually only officially at level two
autonomy where a driver needs to pay
attention at all times one thing that's
almost certain is that these moves will
be closely watched by regulators who
have been keeping a watchful eye over
these companies in 2021
but it's not just our roads that we'll
see change in 2022 one of the biggest
questions in the aviation industry is
whether travel especially lucrative
business travel will return to
pre-pandemic levels next year if the
industry doesn't recover soon we could
see carriers reconfiguring their
aircraft to try and generate more
revenue from things like premium economy
we might also see the initial steps
towards a return to supersonic flight
boom supersonic has said that they have
plans to fly their supersonic x-1b
demonstrator plane sometime next year
boeing's 737 max could also resume
flights in china next year after the
country's aviation authority issued a
key safety approval for the plane and
that could pave the way for new orders
for boeing and then there's the aviation
sector's ambitions to decarbonize while
2021 saw some airlines voluntarily sign
up to an ambition of net zero emissions
by 2050 next year could see the un's
international civil aviation
organization codify that ambition into a
global target
and then there's space after a record
year for space tourism now many
companies are aiming for the moon
spacex's long-anticipated starship
rocket is scheduled for its first
orbital test launch next year also
launching next year will be phase one of
nasa's artemis mission which eventually
plans to land humans on the moon once
more 2022 might also see some leaps
forward in terms of making space a
little bit more affordable rocket
manufacturer relativity space have
developed a 3d printed rocket which the
company says is cheaper and quicker to
manufacture than conventional rockets
they launch the terran 1 early next year
so while nasa's artemis mission isn't
set to land on the lunar surface till
the middle of the decade you can bet
that next year we'll see companies
paving the way and competing to get
there so there you have it just a hint
of what we might see next year but
remember with the ongoing coronavirus
pandemic supply chain log jams and the
global chip shortage it's anyone's guess
as to how next year might actually pan
out and if there's one thing this year
has taught me it's to expect the
unexpected hey i just wanted to say a
huge thank you to everyone that's
subscribed to the channel this year we
started out in august and in a few short
months we've racked up around 2 000
subscribers and over 100 000 collective
video views so a big thanks to you for
being here see you next year
[Music]